the jurogan experience jamie i'm gonna
send you something
is me reacting to him knocking out
volkov
[Laughter]
this is one of my favorite one of my
favorite clips
because that knockout was so crazy we
were in the middle here it is right here
i'm gonna set it to you right now jamie
yeah i just uh airdropped it to you amen
why is it not working
all right is it going through i've got
two jamie vernon's here
okay i'll try both of them
you got it okay so that fight to me
was uh a perfect example of one of the
reasons why people love you
is because at any moment in the fight
yeah you could end that [ __ ]
and that was a fight where you were you
were behind on the judge's scorecards
and we were just saying it doesn't
matter like
at any moment derek could knock him out
like that's the thing that's
exciting about you but the ufc because
we go so crazy
the ufc's decided to put these cameras
on us give me some volume on this
[Applause]
look at everybody going crazy we were
going
i had to get up i had to stand up i
couldn't take it
that was so nuts my coach um my manager
my manager at home he fainted
lou lou said he fainted he couldn't take
it either no more so everyone was just
so
so pumped about that and i heard that
some police was called because my
neighbors
our fans was um just going crazy
oh that was that was wild that was one
of the best come from behind knockouts
ever i mean but it was it was wild too
because we
just got done saying like don't count
him out
at any moment he could knock him out and
then boom you catch him with a big punch
and then drop him and then boom put him
away
we went nuts i like whenever my coach
said okay we got a minute left
30 seconds left then i'm like okay
try the game so i got i have to let
everything out
um a lot of my fights i finished in the
last few seconds of the fight
so i like the the weight the last minute
or last two minutes
left to really show what i got left in
my tank
so but that shows your hard work that
you can keep that power
in in like deep into the fight that
means you've did the work in the gym
like you still have the the gas yeah
yeah
was that your most satisfying knockout
that was yeah
the crowd made it real exciting and
satisfying because the way they reacted
you know then seeing that one guy that
played in um
the one movie um
grunt group brute what movie is that
guardians guardians of the galaxy oh
chris pratt yeah
yeah yeah he's seen history seeing his
reaction it was like
he made it all work well yeah yeah no
that was a big one that was a big one
yeah i wish the fans was here for the
curtis fight i'm pretty sure they would
have went crazy for that one too
a hundred percent i screamed in my house
i screamed in my house my wife
every now and then in the fight like you
know when i'm watching fights at home i
scream
and then my wife has to realize i'm
watching fights because i'm by myself in
the theater going wow
yeah that was that was one that um for
sure would have got a giant reaction
from the crowd
yeah is it yeah is
so what is like do you have a favorite
moment as a fighter
or do you have you have so many
knockouts yeah
you're the most knockouts ever in the
heavyweight division yeah that's crazy
because i wasn't even really going for
that
um my favorite one it has to be volkov
the phone call because i was telling my
coaches
and my camp before that fight it's like
i'm fighting a russian guy
it'd be cool if i could get one of those
rocket type fights
and showing up it was a rocket type
fight and like
so crazy so crazy it ended just like a
rocky movie
yeah there it is boom
my goodness that was crazy then like a
few minutes before that he's
i hit him and he's saying that his
mouthpiece was my mouthpiece i said nah
that's not my mom
i said okay i guess yeah that
that was pitch that that ko back up to
the the right hand again that drops him
that [ __ ] was picture perfect
here it is boom i mean
timing distance everything it was
picture perfect and the fact that you
did this deep into the fight look at
this
yeah does this feel does it feel surreal
watching yourself
oh yeah all the time all the time
when you watch yourself on television
like what goes through your head
when you see something like this i'm
like man i don't look that fat in person
whenever i watch my highlight like then
you see me in person like
you lost some weight no i ain't losing
the weight that's the tv
sports fox sport espn i think i look a
little smaller now
fox sports cameras make me look fat
i think everybody thinks they look fat
when they see themselves on television i
think i look fat when i walk by a mirror
i'm like come on really [ __ ]
yeah but you know if you do drop down to
you know whatever you want to get to the
240 or two out of maybe
maybe then you can see a little six-pack
yeah then
you know i'll walk around i walk around
with no shirt
but now i don't like walking around with
shirt with no shirt in front of my sons
my boys they always call me fat
because they got six packs so then like
i make it seem like they don't bother me
but
i gonna cry in a room
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience